hi i'm ryan right and I am Jerry welcome
to our show called reasons to see where
we give you reasons to see and maybe not
to see oblivion so let's hang out sixty
years ago earth was attacked we won the
war but they destroyed half the planet
everyone's been evacuated nothing human
remains our job is security in drone
maintenance where the mother after our
planet Earth has been practically
destroyed due to a war with an alien
race known as the scabs a drone
repairman assigned to extract Earth's
remaining resources begins to question
what he knows about the mission and
himself is he gay that's what he's
questioning reason to see number one Tom
Cruise yes yes yes a billion times yes
I love this actor he's one of my
favorite actors I'm gonna declare that
you know right out loud I don't think a
lot of guys admit to that you know Tom
Cruise being their favorite actor yeah
but i'll gladly admit he's one of my
favorites he's always entertaining he's
always solid he's one of those actors
that he's like a total celebrity you
know what I mean yes Tom Cruise has this
weird thing where people are always like
laughing and being like okay he's
probably running again and being really
intense who are you but then most the
time when people watch his movies or
like Tom Cruise is really good yeah he
will take Tom Cruise's town for granted
I think yeah because he I mean sure he's
not like Johnny Depp or Daniel day-lewis
who will like change his voice and stuff
a lot but the guy is great at what he
does I want to go the first thing pick
up do you have any memories before the
mission before the scare anyone our job
is not to remember remember do you
remember her what I love about him in
this movie is he really showcases his
talent in the sense that this is a
completely fictitious world any really
sells this I don't think this world
would have been as believable if it
wasn't for him believing everything to
the degree that he believes it at he's
laughs again classic classic scene that
[ __ ] trailer so many tired hungry
throws a Hail Mary touch touch down last
super bowl was played right
Jason tell me was a classic classic gave
80,000 people on there eight seconds
left on the clock yep QB throws a Hail
Mary yeah no I mean he's great this
movie and I mean he sells every bit of
it even when it starts to get weird you
know you really you believe what he's
going through and how much it must be
warping his mind Tower we've got
survivors therefore check it fine
survivors they are human
they always entertain a watch always
intense and don't worry people he does
run he does run but he doesn't smile all
the time reason to see number two visual
effects absolutely groundbreaking in my
opinion this movie it's spectacular to
look at to yet hold you know yeah no
absolutely like the visual effects are
just unbelievably top-notch the whole
world they create with all this stuff
there is some gorgeous imagery in there
we've seen a lot of different versions
of the future lately and this one is
kind of interesting because it's so very
sparse you know it's a wasteland it was
only a couple people that aren't that
many structures and stuff like that but
the way the effects enhance the world
around and then the action and
everything is a little the visual
effects looked real you know there's not
there's not a whole lot of action in
this movie so I'm not gonna think we
should make action a category is good
because everybody what I will say is
that when there is action it's certainly
really good it's very entertaining the
visual effects you'll just blow your
mind away I hear that and they shot up
with special IMAX cameras Oh as I didn't
see this in imax I wish I did I just I
just saw it at a regular screen so from
the beginning we knew we wanted this to
play on imax screens town for 9 this is
Mission Control are you an effective
team we are an effective team this is
Jack Harper
I'm good to go I love the scope that it
provides I love the sound our boss just
at a regular screen alone I was blown
away yeah that how and it's not like two
in your face yeah as well you know it's
not like watching a Transformers film
where it's just like bombarded with it
well it's like look at our affair yeah
there's still a sense of reality you
know it's very much it's kind of a
grounded level of special-effects and it
also has a classic site by touch to it
oh yeah it treats all the things that
are effects as if it's part of their
world like everyone like that's how
everything is treated because it is part
of the work it looks real to like when
those drones like come crashing at them
and stuff it looks real it just looks
cool you're out one thing I gotta tell
you is like it just looks cool
everything looks awesome and it feels
cool and it's just like the scapes that
they did a photograph our breath take
they have no special effects production
design all of it just like top-notch
it's crazy how it's a post-apocalyptic
world yeah it's like what a beautiful
post-apocalyptic world to look at oh
yeah the place where the two of them
live like we're a Tom prajakta well yeah
they're lower than sky house thing after
glass pool like oh yeah they live a but
they live in the clouds man it's Korea
they live on this weird elevated house
thing in the closet it's like there's
there's there's some scenes in there
that are just gorgeous to look at where
they're swimming even just taking a
shower I'm just like wow this looks in
great reason to see number three the
directing you know a lot of people are
giving this guy like crap for this film
ya know like I said almost 5050 like one
thing people are saying is oh it just
steals from a bunch of sci-fi films and
in my opinion I think he's like honoring
in a pain homage to what he grew up on
he then rather than stealing from these
films I feel like the only guy who can
get away with paying homage and not get
crap for it is Quentin Tarantino well
magis is a tough thing because if people
like it its own Lodge and if you people
don't like it it's stealing I'm noticing
a lot of people are harder like making
those accusation
like that and it's like yeah to me he's
more borrowing because it does pay
tribute to like a lot of films in a way
like 2001 a Space Odyssey some people
are even saying it's like wall-e and
yeah in a certain sense you know what
this guy created the graphic novel that
this movie is based on and he brought
the world to life and you know with him
behind the camera it wouldn't have been
such a great world to look at well yeah
I mean and also it's a movie that has a
definite aura it has a definite there's
a specific tone to it yeah it's got a
tone in a quality and I think you know
as a director you at least have to have
a handle on that kind of thing it all
feels unified and you know like I wasn't
a fan of tron legacy I I did not like
that movie and wow what a major
improvement in my personal opinion in
terms of storytelling because there are
some confusing plot points here and
there but for the most part it was a
thrilling adventure to keep me
interested even when I'm confused too is
like that's an accomplishment because it
that makes me go I want to watch this a
second time so I can pick up on all the
pieces that I didn't quite get the first
time you know it seems like there was a
strong vision at least for the pace and
the look and the feel and all that stuff
yeah I don't know who drew the comic but
the Dean of the day it was basically
that guy's vision why not be the
collision occurs out yet what happened
was he made the comic and then I believe
disney bought it but then they wanted to
keep it PG they couldn't figure out how
to make a PG without alternating most of
the story so they they basically sold
the rights and universal got it and then
Universal was agreed to a pg-13 rating
based off the comic okay so basically
there is an illustrator and I guess I
did design some images but the comic
itself has not yet been released but
it's kind of cool because it's like a
sword boarded it before they even like
you know how to scream play even
finished beforehand oh yeah it has a you
can like I said you can feel a lot of
the imagery and a lot of the tone you
can feel it kind of resonating out of a
novel or graphic novel as far as a
storytelling aspect went one thing I
really admired about this film was you
don't really know where this movie is
going and I don't mean that in a bad way
yeah I mean like it's not a predictable
adventure or you
kind of predict what the next scene is
gonna be and everything is unfolding
before your eyes and I love watching a
movie that does that you know nowadays
like all the movies that clearly follow
like certain screen writing books and
the things that are so predictable now
think of we need to leave now competent
you are you stealing effective d yeah a
lot of twists and turns and lots of
interesting you know reveals and stuff
like that and I've heard some people
saying that some of its predictable but
to me like you know I mean I can see it
in a way how because it is pretty much a
classic sci-fi film in a way like a lot
of the way how things work it's not one
hundred percent original but for the
most part I don't consider it something
where it's like yeah I could have
predicted that was gonna happen I think
the most I'm looking back at a lot of it
in your like there's no way I would have
predicted that
you know I wish you could do a spoiler
review in a way because there is a lot
of twists and turns but it goes far
beyond twists and turns it's just the
actual storytelling itself just has a
lot of interesting aspects to it this
war
certainly for sho sho nuff reason to see
number four the score within the first
few minutes of this film I was like I
already love this score that music was
[ __ ] awesome
it's such a unique sound and it fits the
with a movie so well there was one point
that it wasn't too like after the
midpoint of the phone words sounded a
little bit like Batman to me well it was
like it was like Batman circuit tech job
yeah that's a girl eager to put it and
the score is actually by a band called
m83 who is there midnight city is big on
the radio right now and they're actually
a really cool choice I think to do this
kind of movie because I don't have a ton
of experience with their music with what
I have heard it is very sort of lush and
soundscape II and kind of fitting for an
apocalyptic you know space land I wanted
to buy the album for this movie like
right away and how definitely it's great
I can't wait to download it he's a
fantastic science fiction director and
he knows how to find the right composers
Matt for sure boom the show reason to
see number five this intimate ography
cinematography is basically everything
to do with the camera so it's the
lighting the framing you know how the
movie is captured otherwise known as
director of photography we're saying
that because we've gotten some people
saying and we don't know is
cinematography is so we figure we'll
explain that up and the cinematography
in this film yes yeah orgasmic the guy
who did this cinema trouble is his name
Claudio Claudio Miranda Claudio Moretti
just won the Oscar for life of pp hahaha
pun no one no one has said that no one
like I have come up with that joke it's
just like winters bone oh god did you
just make that up you know that feels so
good you know today would be a good day
to die with a heart on a good day to die
hard well anyway he won the Oscar for
Life of Pi the American Pie sequel we're
just gonna does nail this one and he
also did that the curious case of
benjamin button the dip tron legacy as
well after working on tron legacy i
guess you know these two really just
know how to work together well cuz tron
legacy look great and this film looks
even better in my opinion yeah i mean it
looks awesome because there's one thing
you know like to pull off a whole
digital world and stuff like that i mean
yes it's very impressive but i'm
actually more impressed when you put a
bunch of visuals and the
reality will in the real world because
to make that look real it is even more
difficult and just the way how
everything was captured oh wow
absolutely just perfect don't have to
die they don't have to die
it sounded am hopeful from what I
couldn't do that
earth is my home
everything is really gorgeously composed
like it's all really awesome to look at
on top of that too with the editing
working together as well just wow is
with directing cinematography and
editing just the perfect combo mix in
this film this makes for a great summer
film yeah you know what I mean and it
goes above this summer film in my
opinion because there's a lot of story
in this movie it's not like it's trying
to move from one big set piece to the
next or anything like that it's like
there is action and all the action looks
really good but there's lots of other
stuff too there's only action when there
needs to be I know they found in Iceland
I was at saying so I mainly you know I
son I hear is like daylight forever over
there and we're at the top of the globe
no I guess so yeah here like for most
the majority the day of sunlight
actually the landscape looks like really
need no other place on earth it's a
volcanic island black sands no trees
there's a beauty in the desolation there
and that seemed to kind of fit the
aesthetic I wanted for Oblivion we were
there when it was daylight for 24 hours
hey I i I'm just overwhelmed by how
great everything behind the camera was
reasons not to see Morgan Freeman is
barely in it I know he gets second
billing and he's all over the video Oh
all of his scene is in the gym
I've been watching you jack you're
curious what are you looking for in
those books if you bring back old
memories he won't get anything from me
my memories been wiped to protest
security of the mission yes you can't
have your precious memory falling into
the wrong hands okay mary has more than
one see you but I know it's it's still
like this dude barely in it there's much
less of him than the trailer would have
you believe oh absolutely they have you
believe he comes in wait earlier and at
the same time they have you believe he's
in it a lot more yeah he's a pivotal
character reason he's certainly an
important character and he does a great
job in it but he is barely in the back
in movies what decisions this is where
Jerry and I don't agree on something
confusing plot points around I'd say the
last third of the film some stuff start
to become very confusing for me but it
wasn't to the point where it it pulled
me out of the movie it pulled me out
slightly but what I was still engrossed
in it I was still like enjoying the tone
the visuals the experience the thrill
ride I was still really digging all that
but i will say there was story elements
that were not very clear for me and the
whole group i was wit it was very
confused as well there's only one person
her group who understood everything and
when i was walking out of the theater i
heard a lot of people talking amongst
themselves too because they were all so
confused I know you weren't though there
are certain little lines here there that
are hard to catch but I feel like you
know it is more things unfolded and
explained itself more I found myself
getting everything so yeah I mean Oh bot
I'm line you might get confused you
might not I can see how someone would
get confused you just got to pay
attention to the movie it's one of those
films that requires you to pay attention
Ryan's consensus there are some
fantastic reasons to see oblivion there
are some fantastic reasons to see
oblivion Tom Cruise and crew working
well together this makes for an awesome
sci-fi film Jerry's consensus I think
there are a lot of strong reasons to see
oblivion there are a lot of strong
reasons to see you
Libyan yeah i mean the look the tone you
know all the characters and stuff like
that it's a really cool movie and you
know it borrows from some other films
here and there but as it as its own
experience it's really awesome don't ask
too many questions they are humid is
also an usual time to tower yuck how do
you know my name they're firing on
survivors
they will start to be fine
you're looking for a truth
that's where you'll find
you know the trailer might make it look
like it is this thrill ride but now
there's the story in it that was little
need your attention span closely alright
guys thanks for checking out our show
please go ahead scroll that comment box
and you know tell us your reasons to see
you or not to see oblivion or if you
haven't seen yet tell us why you want to
go watch it more why you don't want to
go watch it just tell us something mu
just want to hear what you got to say
and while I write it click over to our
channel and check out our reasons to see
trailer thon review show it's brand
spankin new if you're looking for
something a little more in depth than
your typical trailer review show if you
want to see my straight to the point
review of oblivion if you want to know
what the difference is just hear the
title it's straight to the point get it
here my more wacky side click on the
link right here and if you want to check
out more episodes of reason see click
the link right here and last but not
least please if you want to get updated
every time a new review is out go ahead
and subscribe click on the box people
click on it otherwise your life will be
oblivious know you try to round it there
we go
you